you can't fight with people to whom  nothing matters so I decided I'm just  going for the joy that's Roseanne Barr  on Tuesday speaking on Rabbi Shmuel EES  podcast at stand-up new york ET was  exclusively at the taping there are so  many people who are suffering and feel  wronged and like you know I have in the  past and I just want to say have a blast  just take just take an hour if you can  and go dance and feel joy because that's  your real weapon against darkness  Roseanne also opened up about her former  co-star John Goodman who publicly  supported her after her racist tweet  scandal I mean so sweet of him to do  that so nice because he does know me huh  how much did that support me to you I  cried my boyfriend was like look look at  what he said I was so  you